good evening everyone hi my name is
Larry Gallagher and on behalf of MIT
video productions and MIT music in
theatre arts I'd like to welcome you to
this very special program I'd
particularly like to welcome mi t--'s
president and first lady Raphael and
Chris Wright and of course our very
special guests
Jakob Collier
Jakob's residency last fall at MIT is
the subject of the documentary that
we're about to screen following the
screening Fred Harris the director of mi
t--'s wind and jazz ensemble will
moderate a brief Q&A session that is
going to include key contributors to the
film and the concert the evenings
program will conclude with a special
performance by Jakob
soyou Joong Geun ye the film's director
will introduce the film in just a moment
but first I'm very pleased to introduce
mi t--'s president rafael rife well good
evening everyone just there was no way I
was gonna miss this evening no way three
reasons one is never in my life I've
been invited to a movie premiere this is
my shot and I was not gonna miss that
that's number one number two I really
wanted to meet Jacob Collier very much
wanted to meet him I've heard so much
about him and I wanted to hear about
himself and about his music and about
what he did at MIT and and I also heard
that he has claimed that MIT is his
second home so I will come here to say
welcome back home and there is a third
reason there is one other reason what I
wanted to be here and that is to
recognize one of a most special talent
of mi piel MIT this is a fellow who is
known in some circles as the Ken Burns
of MIT do you know who I'm referring to
I'm talking about mr. Larry Gallagher
I think
I think all of you know all of you I'm
sure know that Larry and his MVP team
they got an Emmy Award over the summer
for his documentary a bold move that
describes the move of MIT from Back Bay
to Cambridge and that was not it that
was his second Emmy Award because the
same team got an Emmy Award a few a
couple of years ago both of them very
richly deserved so I want you to take
this opportunity Larry to say to you
thank you for telling the MIT story with
so much care love and elegance and the
your team the MVP team for all the
terrific work they do for MIT thank you
so very much and congratulations
well it's a thrill to be here it's a
thrill to be are sharing this film with
you tonight and thank you very much
Raphael for those very kind words I this
this is really a passion project so it
was extraordinary to spend all this time
with so many people many of which are in
this room tonight who have so much
energy to create and and and I think
that that energy for creation and doing
it in a collaborative way it's kind of a
way for us to you know enjoy our lives
as to the fullest and so I think this
project was definitely that for me and I
hope for all all the others who are here
tonight and the audience and also to
make document documentary films the
hardest part is funding them and so I
wanted to give my gratitude to Neil and
Jane Pappalardo who have given MIT video
productions the space to create to tell
the incredible stories that are going on
every day at MIT and so we get a chance
to pick those stories and tonight you
get to see one of them so I hope you
like it and I'm be here afterwards if
you have any questions or you want to
hear me talk about the film I could go
on forever all right enjoy the show and
it's about to start
[Applause]
[Music]
we are making music with one of the most
talented people I've ever met named
Jacob Collier in the music world
Jacob's huge you know and and so in some
ways for him to get to work with all
these musicians the best manner
[Music]
and we were able to get him to come to
MIT and kind of do a week-long residency
[Applause]
[Music]
mi t--'s visiting artists program is
trying to bring great artists in
substantive contact with our students
it's all about music education
experiences I wanted them to feel the
sparks of Jacob's creativity firsthand
and I wanted them to go beyond that to
get inside his music and to be able to
make it their own but this kind of thing
is all you really need is like
[Music]
you could even find like a I mean I do
your anything you could find a rift I
think that's just kind of like just like
because I guess the guitar is like
basically a drummer I supposed to be a
hard instrument he creates a really
great atmosphere for working with people
and bringing the best out of them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Megan amazing it's a creative
environment that really feeds me their
minds our officers have shark you know
and it's not even necessarily musically
sharp in the foreground but these guys
think about stuff there's this gig on
Saturday that if you don't have tickets
to I believe there's a waiting list but
you should come it's gonna be so crazy
200 musicians on the stage
I'm performing with Jacob Collier which
is amazing
[Music]
when I listen to his music he liked
since joseph of mike respond especially
hideaway like that's my favorite song
[Music]
a sense of peace sense of calm and
something making sense
[Music]
when I started listening to the music I
realized this was a lot more complicated
than most arranging projects
[Music]
as a music nerd is a beautiful-looking
score to me because there's all these
things that didn't appear like they
should be there from the beginning and
they start to show up
[Music]
his music is in many ways like classical
music which is that so much of it is
specified you know that man
it's pretty moving for some people
hideaway especially there are certain
points on the music where it's pretty
overwhelming so
like the cause so he states the melody
he sings the melody it's all very tonal
and pretty and like a pop song and then
we get to the bridge and suddenly he
throws us for a loop
[Music]
like uh never
[Music]
in place that are
[Music]
in my
the drummer has one of the hardest
things of all he's got to play the fives
on the cymbal but still maintain the
slow forward with his foot
[Music]
my heart
[Music]
in the second verse he adds this layer
of fives so
and it's made more complex by the fact
that the 5s are grouped in fours and
threes and sixes
[Music]
[Music]
it's you know you don't hear the math of
it when you're listening to the song you
just suddenly become unmoored than these
kind of dreamlike state and yet you
still hear the slow pulse from the
original part of the song he's kind of
playing with this notion of you the
listener thinking you know where you are
and he'll throw something at you that
unmoor is it but without completely
divorcing you from the structure that
you knew before
[Music]
[Music]
it's just it's a revelation it's amazing
and all of this is happening you know in
what at the beginning seemed to be a
simple four chord pop song
[Music]
this is kind of what our lives are like
is that we try to reduce them so that we
can get through the day but the stuff
going on that if we just pay attention
to it is beautiful inspiring frightening
and he's kind of encapsulating all of
this in in a five or six minute song
that appears to be a pop ballad at the
beginning
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
aha
it was just like everything I had ever
wanted to hear in music because it's so
intricate in detailed but it's
purposeful it like he has a purpose for
everything he does every note he hits
every weird beat that he plays
[Music]
what my mom did is recognized that I had
some kind of weird brain that was very
thirsty and very inventive and quite
emotionally mature and presented lots of
different things to me like this is bark
this is Stravinsky this is Bartok unsub
written this is Earth Wind and Fire this
bub McFerrin this is sting those are
like a lot of my heroes growing up um
and I and I wasn't told to do anything
with them I was just told to enjoy them
she used to do things like turn on the
vacuum cleaner always be telling you hey
the Hoover and plug it into a sage a
cabal no does that feel like in someone
I'm 2 2 years old like gee so yeah
Sergey really the biggest gift I was
given as a child was a space and the
affirmation to create in it I was never
ever told to practice ever
it was never taught to practice and
people don't believe that no way no
where's the discipline it's not a thing
and and and it's funny because it's true
but people have an idea of how to learn
and how to teach that I think is
horrific ly out of date
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I like going to at the beginning for
Django the first thing you hear is the
strings come in it's like the announcing
of the new song yeah so I call it to
change your texture for that that's cool
do you want to do those edits you can
plug in the speakers and do those ads
I'd love that
yeah can we look at a microphone yeah
[Music]
by some one of his videos on YouTube and
I thought oh my gosh this guy's amazing
he's got this great sense of aesthetics
and editing skills and mixing and all
these things and I like to build music
tech stuff and so I sent him a Facebook
message saying I'm in MIT I make stuff
have you any ideas of stuff you'd like
to make and I said oh well yes I have
I've always dreamed of singing harmony
on the spot gonna be able to essentially
improvise a choir a harmonizer takes
whatever you're singing and there's a
keyboard and you can play different
notes and the notes that you play are
transformed so that what you sing is
spread across lots and lots of notes
basically multiplies his voice and
stacks
[Applause]
[Music]
because this is like woodwind alone sex
those sounds go together don't they yeah
I'm gonna be creating this kind of
improvised harmonic more spontaneous
technological musical compound piece
where I can send the musicians
information during the performance via
maybe iPad screens or something like
this where I say you play these notes
now and they play an expose up and slows
down and then I can fill in the gaps and
it's like a big conversation and this is
one of the main pieces of work that will
be done between now and December I think
one stage you will you'll need one
laptop that'll be the MIDI input okay
and that'll have a keyboard
[Music]
we each open up a web page on our phone
and there's a staff so he's picking all
of these different notes chords rhythms
everything for every different
instrument and we're playing them as
they come up on our screen it's allowing
Jacob to literally play the band in real
time
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a scientist I'm an engineer too so I
like to tinker I like to explore things
and one of my best laboratories is is is
with music so I think if anything Jacob
has made us into bolder risk more
risk-taking experimentalists alone
perhaps more about how it's best not to
learn and not to teach then how to learn
and how to teach don't keep people all
the answers to things you give people
all the answers then they are the
subject to your criteria but if you give
them all the questions in the clues then
they find their own answers and actually
the process of finding an answer is
almost all of learning so I think
teachers have a responsibility to trust
their students to find not only answers
but their own answers that might be
different from the teachers answers
especially when it comes summer light
jazz which is so vague and so expressive
and personal
[Applause]
[Applause]
I had an idea for like for the section
whether it goes in tank yeah I could be
them the rhythm at what stage of the
process you write the lyrics it depends
sometimes it's the first thing that I
write I write a lot I write I have a
thought but it's filled with words
really dense imagery like really
interesting dense imagery I want to come
try lyrics I try and write as little of
it as I can because the music is already
called Beck's and I need to allow people
to find their own meanings in the words
like this on her Django it's just a
number of seven syllable lines everybody
near and far come together as you are
and to the ocean to the sky seeing that
cosmic lullaby that could mean lots of
different things that could mean life
and death it could mean a simple song of
your mother's you see if we go to sleep
it could mean the actual universe like
lots of different things
[Music]
I'd rather bright words they invite
people to understand and rather than
reject my understanding or to other
people
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody near fall
[Music]
go together
[Music]
to the ocean to
signai single John
[Music]
sing your pleasure sing your pain
[Music]
that go down
ancients right
[Music]
when the good days buzzer bye
[Music]
there's a gun
[Music]
when those dog loves bring it down
your hands of the sky
[Music]
as the words round around around
the tears roll down
see
you wish to
[Applause]
[Music]
when old Starbuck renewed
spark Lovejoy
[Music]
breakdown
[Music]
your voice is from your heart
[Music]
and every night through that dog lies to
the line
ah drive see the tell you
the winter comes the spring it don't
matter what I'll baby
[Music]
see you
[Music]
stop
[Music]
sir
[Music]
[Music]
nothing
[Music]
so do things you know
[Music]
the general
[Music]
probably business whole week but if you
ever find like an hour you want to go
grab a pint anyway yeah yeah yeah
fantastic are you gonna be throwing your
Saturday I just find me off to them so
I'll be hanging out all right Sheila I
really feel like MIT is a sort of second
home in some ways I've always very much
felt some kind of kinship with this kind
of idea of celebrating the introvert MIT
it's a sort of sublime understanding of
the people who think in words first I
would count myself in amongst a group of
people so I'd like to celebrate that
idea I think I'm being at MIT
consistently reminds me how wonderful it
is when people think beyond this level
and up and down into the other realms of
things so I'd like to sort of say thank
you to MIT as a concept
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if the goose thing and the basically
[Music]
it's cool right
it's like it's more cool than 2 to 2
because they have a gravity that goes
towards the same place but they don't
have a unison line let's try to figure
this is a GU that's hard to nail finish
the groove on their on their on the
record and it's like it like a little
groove so it's it's less of a shuffle
and it's like halfway between a shuffle
and a normal groove so this is straight
and then this is true it's like coffee
bean it's less about putting the hi-hat
later it's more like bringing the snare
earlier if I see but if I play and then
you guys can join in maybe that's
sous-vide in the field
[Music]
[Music]
very carefully and deliberately swings
it in certain ways and modulates the
time and pulls and pushes in a way that
just gets this like really visceral
groove where you just like get into it
so much
that little bit of extra effort to you
know change it makes such a difference
and that's such a a Jacob constructs
isn't that extra bit of intention that
just you know even just a tiny little
breath I'm a tiny little extra note or
something that doesn't quite you know
fit in what the rules say they're
supposed to do what sue had you guys
split into two sections of what you sing
at different things put your hand in the
air if you people need to sing along
with in this next song with me and by
that I mean everybody raise your hand
this is a song called Savior
it's the lawsuit of the night thank you
so so much for coming this must be what
Quincy Jones felt when he first
encountered Stevie Wonder or Michael
Jackson but here's someone who has
really really deep musical resources is
marshaling this at a young age he has
phenomenal performance skills arranging
skills composition skills it's just
incredible that all this exists in a
single person
[Music]
[Music]
she wants to touch down below a knockoff
she's never gonna
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you search for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the way he performs is enthralling I
can't even begin to imagine his
potential I mean he's only what 22 I
just think all of us are so incredibly
lucky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's one of those once-in-a-lifetime
kind of people that changes the way you
look at things
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's really inspiring it makes me think
that there's real divinity in the world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
see take these broken wings and learn to
fly all your life you were only waiting
for this moment - for this mama - but
[Music]
sometimes let's see lunacy let's see all
your mom on TV -
I'm so happy and this is what Jacobs
spirit does I mean it just he makes you
happy yeah in so many deep ways can I
just get a quick show of hands of how
many people were involved in that whole
residency whether you're a musician or
you were behind the scenes raise your
hand if you were involved in some way or
another reason honey thank you so much
because this really started as a dream
that grew and grew and grew and it was
fabulous we're gonna have give the
audience a chance to ask questions of
all these amazing people but I want to
say one thing and I've always been in
awe of the ephemeral nature of music
it's of live performance because once
you do it it's done you can never
recapture it quite the same way again
and this always makes me exhilarated but
it always makes me sad so that what I
find is that after a really good
concerts I'm rather depressed for a
while usually an hour or two after this
concert weeks I was depressed so I thank
you all for that great feeling of
depression we're going to do this QA and
I think you know everybody but I just
want to introduce first and foremost
here is gem Sharif the class of 83
we might get some questions about this
but Jamshid is a fantastic composer and
arranger producer he was the director of
the MIT festival jazz ensemble for seven
years took it on after he graduated and
he had the incredible I still don't know
how he did it task of not only
transcribing Jacobs music but arranging
it for very large forces so Jamshid
Sherif II then yes of course you've
already met John dune why a our
wonderful film director and editor and
of course the brilliance in ever
innovative media mastermind of MIT and
well beyond Ben Bloomberg
[Music]
and of course the magical jacob collier
whose capacity for creativity with heart
knows no limits Jacob
so here's your chance anybody has a
question we just asked you come down
there's a mic on either side any
question of any of these folks would be
great to have hi I have a really
exciting editing question if there's
such thing uh for Jacob and free of the
filmmaker how do you take something like
that like all that happened and be and
to make to be concise as a filmmaker and
not make it a Peter Jackson Lord of the
Rings movie with 9 and 19 endings and
like is there a part of it like letting
go and also I guess with arranging your
music with all these people and it could
be like a 10 hour long concert so how do
you like how much of it is letting go of
what of attachments and stuff like that
to make the whole thing better that
question so really what it is is you
spend a lot of time looking at your
footage and you're you're looking for
the for the peaks for the real like
moments when everything's kind of
coalescing perfectly and when you're
making film there's always some things
that just fall off the edge that just
don't work at all or you know that great
shot you want it just didn't happen and
and so you you really look at your
footage to to concentrate the energy on
the bits that really fly so we had
within the case of the rehearsal for
example we had you know I ended up
boiling it down to about 20 minutes of
rehearsal and I loved all of it but you
know once I get to that point then then
I've decided I like those 20 minutes and
then I just kind of choose the bits that
that illustrate what might have happened
before and after in terms of the song
that you're hearing before or after you
know in performance so those are kind of
some of the thought processes that I go
through with editing it's really about
like like finding the nectar you know
squeezing it to the to the maximum I
don't
Jacob mustards yeah I can I can relate
to that for sure I think for me when it
comes to making music there's always
that the sorrow of of letting go of a
good idea right this is very sad
however I've always had this idea a
slight sort of mechanism for dealing
with this kind of thing where I often
record ideas on on voice memos so it's
like and I whisper to myself how to
create it how to manifest from that from
that point and all sorts of things I
then take that idea and put it in a
Timeline view
I then cut it up in color code it in
sort of gold silver and bronze ideas and
bronze ideas are like filler and in my
case those are sometimes quite extreme
already silver ideas are kind of other
moments that make you go oh that's crazy
and then gold moments are like mic drop
moments you know and and and my
challenge is always to have to have the
patience and and trust the listener to
leave the gold ideas to the end because
I want to do them all at once and I've
always had a sort of love and my
intuition has always found that doing
everything at once is really fun and the
older I get you know now now I'm all
grown up yeah and and I think I'm
learning that you know it's it's that
tricky thing of the more you know how to
do the more courage it takes not to do
it all at once but but the more you have
to cut that said courage the greater the
sort of depth of the of the end result
of something so you know I think it's a
process of understanding your own
process for me it's about letting
everything come out everything's to come
out all the ideas all of the visions all
of the various things that one juggles
in the koto process I think that if you
don't let that come out then there's
something that is never going to be done
as a result bless you
and so everything everything comes out
and then one needs the the courage to
deal with each thing as it is and then
to place it where it needs to be placed
if that makes any sense
Jakub given whatever preconceived
notions you had about MIT and you know
we all had them before we came and
discovered when MIT is all about given
those preconceived notions which
surprised you most about interacting
with these wonderful students yeah yeah
fantastic question so I mean I've I feel
like I had school
the surface of what MIT was all about
because I've been hanging with them for
a while I guess a year that's a while
two years two years and you know I think
I was you know I was expecting some some
some fun and I was expecting some some
innovation but the kinds of the this
theum the quality of the brilliance of
the mines was just blew me away at the
moment I came in and I came in in
September right and sort of dipped my
toe in and I think that's where we've
got some of the rehearsal footage from
that initial rehearsal time and it's
like these guys are just alive you know
and when you see when you look someone
in the eye and their eyes are going it's
just that that I connect without so much
and it's wonderful and you know and
often with collaborations and especially
with teaching and you come to these
institutions to teach whatever that
happens to me I know these sort of these
students with no eyes looking at you in
the audience and but here it's like
everyone's just ready they're just
they're thirsty and ready and and
they're like sponges so you know you say
an idea once and it sticks so it
everybody and that's so rare I can't
tell you how rare that is and and then
you know obviously when when you
rehearse it's exciting and when you
arrange and discuss it's exciting but
when you when everyone gets on that
stage no one really knows what's going
to happen you know I mean me and Fred
had discussed it at length at the
different sections and the order of the
songs and things but things change so
fast and then you're taken by surprise
and I think the you know for for a
collective group of people who are
perhaps used to organizing things and
frameworks and understanding that things
happen in a certain order and and you
know these are the sort of the greatest
science and maths brains of our
generation but then you know you could
drop a bomb and then people will respond
and I think that was something I wasn't
expecting at all but something I was
later to find you're welcome
this is for Jacob so you've obviously
used like extensive music technology and
you're here because you're like pushing
the limits of it
what kind of music technology do you
have like musical visions for in the
distant future for the tech that's like
not even close and also a second
question do you want to grab a pint
after this see you there - the former I
guess Ben and I can answer this question
together um yeah so when when Ben's him
in his Facebook message it was very
thrilling for me and actually was it was
serendipitous that I even saw it because
I tend to stay clear of Facebook
messages you know cuz it's in minefield
and you know you never know what weird
stuff you're gonna find and just it just
so happened that one day out of you know
in three or four weeks I decide to check
them out and on the top of the pile was
you know Ben Ben Bloomberg and so just
have clicked on his name and and then
notice this it wasn't long it was a
short paragraph it basically just I'm
you boys say better than I can but this
he just said you know I've just seen a
video of yours and I think it's it's
it's exciting and and I just I create
things I love to create things and to me
that was like well that's me as well I
love to create things but but Ben likes
to create sort of digital I performance
flavored things and and yeah it was I
guess as you saw in the documentary was
kind of like do you want to make
anything and the answer that was a was
an absolute yes and and we jumped on
skype and spoke for I think three three
hours and it and it was just like you
know I've been waiting how how old was I
at the time 19 or 20 I'll be waiting 20
years for that conversation so it was it
was like and Ben was just a Ben was just
astounding because you know it'll be
very easy just to say well you know
that's that's a lot of stuff and you
know that was fun goodbye
you know sort of thing but but you know
but I think partly because a lot of the
stuff just wasn't really possible and
still some of it still is not possible
and and some of it has been made
possible by Ben which is just astounding
um and I guess the first thing I wanted
to tour my room
right I went to tour my room which is
not a conventional way of touring
because normally one would talk with a
band but I want to tour with a room and
I wanted to be able to sing in harmony
on the spot
Jonah explained bit by bit about the
harmonizer and how we did it and how it
works and yeah that whole shebang I mean
so it's it's sort of all of our
favourite sounds in one box and there
are a lot of other sort of approaches to
similar things like phase vocoders and
and all kinds of things out there but
first thing first thing Jacob said is
well all the ones I could find only have
four notes and I want to play way more
than four notes at a time and so so for
the first thing we did was we started to
try to figure out how to make one that
could play a gazillion notes
simultaneously and it was like well what
if you what if you know I play a chord
and then I want to keep that one going
and then play something else on top of
it and so so we came up with but this
thing actually it's right there which is
a bunch of electronics and software and
and some off-the-shelf stuff and some
custom stuff and and yeah I guess I
guess that was sort of the first thing
we sat we sat together we did ruin about
a weekend yeah Jacob came to Boston to
visit and we put it all together and
then we started thinking about other
stuff yeah yeah I mean it's it's an
ongoing challenge it's like how do you
you know as a human being how can I make
my creative process bigger without
detracting from my humanity that's the
thing isn't it because technologies of
Steel's humanity sometimes Stowe's it
away in some invisible dangerous place
and I think there for me it's it's that
thing of you know if I if I had eleven
arms or twelve arms I would try and play
it into all the instruments at once but
I don't so the only way to do it is to
try and use our imaginations about how
to achieve that but the goal is is kind
of like more human rather than removed
from human I think and that's a that's
an aesthetic that we shared and share
moving forward out there there's so much
to do within the world of technology but
but it has to feel like it you can touch
it and you can feel it and and the
moment you touch it it kind of gets you
out of yourself because for me those are
the best creative processes it does
matter whether it's
or a base or a computer or something
it's like if you touch it and it goes
then you want to create into it and so
yeah we've got a bunch of strange
projects that are flying around like
that this is the harmonizer and there's
now soon to come the vocalizer which is
a dangerous sample library made of
voices that does and various other
things and then there is yeah we're
trying to figure out a way to
essentially teach a computer how to
navigate harmony and then present to
humans the the user interface with which
they can interact using their own
emotional criteria to navigate so they
don't have to be musicians to know that
you know if you add a to that chord it
warms your heart up you know but if I
can just put that in someone's hand but
but they don't have to say okay it's an
a minor chord and I'm adding your D they
can just say I want to just go and then
they make it a can have it so it's it's
a it's a bit of a romantic idea but
we're working towards it a piece by
piece work we are going to tackle that I
mean I think a big challenge especially
with the technology stuff figuring out
actually what the tech is good for and
what what Jacob is good for basically
and so a lot of people build systems
especially for live performance and
you're trying to lean on the computer to
do something that just a human is always
gonna do better and you know maybe maybe
10 years 20 years down the road we'll
have something that does it but but when
you look at it right now and you're
thinking about an experience for you
know for people in an audience you know
Computers Computers do certain things
really really well but we do certain
things really really well and so sort of
finding the optimal synergy there as
sort of what we're what we're excited
about working on computers never gonna
follow a score you know as well as a
human can at least in the next two and a
half years so you know so maybe we'll
wait two and a half years you know but
but it's it's those are that those are a
lot of the kinds of decisions and and
and sort of philosophies that we think
about you know sort of yeah where can we
apply the technology in a way
where it's actually it's actually doing
something that it's you know that helps
that that makes the performance of our
musical analogy your anecdote with the
vacuum cleaner reminded me of this
so in pieces like in the Bleak Midwinter
and fascinating rhythm you display this
micro turn micro tonally perfect sense
of perfect pitch how much of that was
just something you've always had and how
much of that was developed interesting
question so so perfect pitch is it's
it's just it's like it's a kind of
memory really it's it's being able to
recall a sound and I suppose the more
I've recorded things over the years the
more I've realized that this is not in
tune it's not in tune at all to very
quickly demonstrate if you if you take a
major try I mean you guys know this
because this is like Pythagoras figure
this stuff out right but but like um you
know on the piano that made this is a G
major chord and the major third is
actually 14 cents too high
which means 14 14 hundredths of a
semitone so the correct one is like
[Music]
it's like that out of tune but like I I
realized this and it's like how does no
one know this stuff man like it's crazy
it's like a hoax and so I I just I just
strive to sing more in tune and had to
disregard computers knowing better than
I did because I had to learn about how
to tune chords by ear and then suddenly
it's like well my perfect pitch declines
that be because it's not a 440 and then
suddenly you learned that there's no
reason why 12 keys oh is this the limit
there are more and then yeah so for
example in the Bleak Midwinter I go to G
1/2 sharp in the fourth verse it's like
just a voyage into a key that is
slightly fresher - everybody's ears that
you're definitely mine because I kind of
got bored of the normal one so I thought
it'd be fun to try things out but you
know I think it's you know it's a matter
I mean anybody with a skill set I'm sure
you guys can relate to this but you know
you have your you have your skills that
you use on a regular basis and then once
those get tired it's to do with you know
knowing how to gather in a way that's
not going to disrupt what you already
have but it's going to push you in and
and and stretch your imagination and
your creative strengths and I just think
for me that the microtonal thing was a
bit of a game that for a while I'm I'm
still into it but there was a while
where I was really into it and you know
voices going you know it was just it was
interesting for me because voices need
to move that's that's it that's that's
the gesture movement and arrival and if
you arrived in a satisfying place it
doesn't matter how you get there so
microtones all know Mike returns it
still does the job so it's just a nice
thing to think about you know it's it's
another example of just thinking in
between the gaps of details and finding
that there's magic in the things that
aren't quantized by which I mean
everything's the same you know like if I
play a groove into logic that's like
this and then I quantize etna goes it's
like it's it's fine and it's accurate
and you know techno guys are going to
dance well to that but but but it's it
you know it's lost its go back to your
question it's lost some of its humanity
because the computers squeezed the
humanity out of that so you know Samba
for example I like that the groove that
it's not straight it rolls like an egg
you know and like once you get to learn
that it's like oh so that's not accurate
then this is just one potential thing
all the symptoms don't have to be the
same size you can go in between and you
can stretch things around no yeah I mean
I could talk for a long time about this
but the basic premise is that things
that are perfect just gender generally
aren't are neither perfect nor moving
and so it's just nice to push as much as
you can the things that we believe to be
straight and correct into places that
have a more bit more of a bit more
potential for unfamiliar emotional
language you might be the only person
other than Jacob with her janga who has
arranged jacob's own music for forces
beyond just Jacob alone and I think it's
supposed to be true yes so how was that
process you actually know when I started
on the on the business of arranging
Jacobs music within about an hour I
realized that I was not going to be able
to to really understand what was going
on inside of it so I called up you guys
and asked for the multi-tracks in other
words for the versions of the songs in
which every element was isolated so that
I could hear them in isolation try to
figure out what was going on and even
with that I mean Ben sent me sessions
that were about 60 tracks wide but a
single track would have I mean it would
be labeled guitar I don't have 12
guitars it
so there was an incredible density in
all of this and I mean typically I'll
spend two or three days on him on a
good-sized arrangement on an arrangement
for Orchestra and all of these for Jacob
were at least eight or nine days because
there was so much decoding and
understanding and really reorienting
myself to what I thought I knew about
music because you were doing I mean
you're saying this but I'm I'm verifying
you're doing stuff that I've never seen
before
that I've never seen people consider in
terms of the way harmonies have put
together in terms of the way the time
was because it definitely wasn't
quantized and yet it grooved its ass off
and uh I was trying to figure out how is
this all working so yeah there were days
of what I'll just call decoding an
analysis of trying to understand where
where it was coming from and then taking
that and you know and putting it on
paper so that us mortals could read it
it was it was revelatory it was really
enjoyable and and eye-opening but yeah
yeah it was a revelation I still feel
that and and feel it more he you know
hearing pieces again
there's so much in what you're doing
that it is that it's at a level I've
never seen before so I don't know
thank you so much
we'll have one more question I think
okay so I was gonna preface this by
asking you if you have any problems but
the real question that I was gonna ask
is what what obstacles have you faced
like because I know I personally suffer
in my artistry from a lot of anxiety and
a lot of like perfectionism paralysis
things just like the the philosophy of
well I mean if you're not gonna do it
right then you shouldn't do it at all
like are there any major things that you
either are currently working through or
you have overcame to become such an
expressive musician that's a that's a
really wonderful question thank you I
know huge question as well
Oh me well it said do you have any
problems would be any problems yeah so
when I go to restaurants and look at the
menu I cannot make a decision about what
does that was it so so I think so okay
so to break this out into short sections
one is is to do with the way that you
learn and the reason that you learn it
and for me as as basically a self-taught
musician I didn't look to other people
for the answers and so I guess I think
was brought up to very much trust my
intuition to lead me in the right
direction and and I think that I enjoyed
the process of arriving at a place more
than I did the place because when you
get to a place it's like okay okay done
you know and for me that's that's always
it's kind of like what Fred was saying
it's like you do all this glorious work
to get to a plant and you do the show
and it's gone and it's bit a little bit
sad um so for me in terms of learning
things it's always just been about sort
of instead of isolating a destination
and then going there and achieving it
and the achieving of it being what keeps
me alive it's like the the varying forms
of nourishment that I'm subject to
during the process of gathering a
particular area within a framework of
something that that process is something
I really enjoy but
I never really minded what other people
thought of what I was doing and I still
don't really mind actually and so you
know the the fact that now I'm I'm
making music and people are like
listening to it and coming to my shows
and things it's it's absolutely
wonderful but it does truly feel like a
bonus to a process that I'd so
thoroughly enjoy that there'd be nothing
that would stop me doing it if nobody
was listening at all so I think you know
to that end you know you people say
people say all sorts of things about
about people you know and so you can you
can be bruised by something that
somebody says about you or to you but
only really if you if you take what they
if you take their opinion as a method
through which you can validate yourself
and for me I've always kind of been of
the belief that I I trust myself by I
love my imagination so much I just I
completely and utterly believe in it and
it's not that I always get it right it's
just that being in there feels really
good and and as a child I just used to
sit you know I can sit in a room just in
heaven with nothing else other than just
like good because my mind because you
know because my mind was was just making
all this stuff happen I'm sure many of
you guys from a little this but one one
particular challenge is that you know an
overactive imagination in education is a
difficult thing to handle and a
difficult thing to be understood by
those around you and so you know for me
it was always Jake who can you just do a
bit less like just just play simple to
get just you know you've got lots of
good ideas Jakob just one one is enough
and you know it's what I played I played
drum kit in the concert band it's cool
and you're on the part it's like and
it's like okay well you know and all
these musicians just trying to play
along with that part and it's like start
Evert stop stop stop
I get Jakob less it less is more less is
more and and it's that is that
interesting thing of less is more
because less is only more when you know
what more is you know and then you can
make a conscious decision to step back
from that and you know for me I think
it's kind
like what I was saying earlier on it's
about you have to let yourself come out
to be able to see your is to be able to
see yourself as raw elements raw
materials and then you can make some
creative decisions about what to do but
you're conscious if you're if you're
constantly pushed back in the shell not
in terms of like in a very negative way
like you're bad or wrong but more just
like there's there's too much that we
can deal with right now so go it back
just just just just wait till you know
just right now you just got to play that
group you know so I think for me as a as
a teenager I just I had trouble relating
to the people around me that were
telling me that things were correct and
incorrect and I think I've learned since
that you know music thank goodness is
it's not you know it's not biology for
example it's not a matter of life and
death it's really just lovely and and
that the the point of music is to
explore what it means to be expressive
and so there is not really such a thing
as this is correct and this is incorrect
and I've never paid too much attention
to you know this is the right note I put
in the call and this is the wrong note
but I think I built as I said I trust
I've trusted my intuitions enough to
gather a sense of I feel this is strong
and this is weak in terms of emotion you
know I maybe say that this voicing it's
not as strong as this voicing because I
don't necessarily want to double the
third as Park would say and I later
learned that Bach said don't double the
third in principle but you know I think
it's it's sort of going back to the
original point it's it's like why do you
do music why'd you do anything and for
me the reason I do music is because I
want to chase those goose bump moment
I'm the moments that just make me go
what is that sound
and how do I understand it how can I
achieve that myself and and you know I
looked around me as a teenager and
nobody else was thinking in those terms
so I just took on upon myself all the
responsibilities of the band members and
gradually you know gradually gather
things but one one problem I've had is
that my my technique my hands I've never
ever been able to catch up with my head
to the point where when I went to jazz
college as an 18 year old for a couple
of
years I was the kid in the class with no
chops but but the years so I could hear
everything that was going on I knew the
notes in the chords and and why
emotionally this one note was just so
tender and stuff like that but I
couldn't just play over Donnelly at 300
BPM I couldn't do that so you know it
was hard to explain why some things are
valid it's hard to explain why certain
things are valuable some underneath
details and I'm sure you guys and gems
here I'm sure and absolutely John can
relate to this because it's to do with
when you create something it's it's
tuning in to all the different levels of
gestures right it's the general gestures
of
its this this is the beginning and this
is the end or it's loud and it's quiet
or it's bright and then it's dark but
but you know there are many gestures
in-between there to do with it's bright
and it's heading towards brightness but
I'm not going to make it bright until
later and like that adds suddenly it's
added a dimension of intention that I
just really enjoy it as a as a teenager
so having the patience to invest in
those parts of your imagination is a
challenge because it's it's fairly glue
it's kind of fairly generally
misunderstood and or dismissed so I
think you know there are always times in
a person's life or you have to think
well why am i doing it again why do I
love this and why is it important to me
and and you know if for example my left
brain takes over which it often does you
know I'm sure some of you guys can
relate to this thinking about thinking
about thinking about thinking can
conundrum right and you know that that's
a problem because it's what if what you
described is sort of paralysis from
analysis type situations where you're
just tied up and you can't even see the
wood for the trees anymore because
you've lost perspective and all of us as
creator people can relate to that thing
when you tune so deeply into a part of a
process that there's just no seeing it
for what it is anymore
and that takes the courage to step away
or get somebody else's opinion and not
be defensive and all sorts of things but
you know I think it's it's coming back
to a place that belongs to you a place
in your mind that belongs to you and and
where your values are safe from others
judgment and you know yeah I could I
could I can speak for a long time about
this so one one other thing I might
quickly mention is that just touring was
exhausting at first because
I'm certainly an introvert so you know
concentrating all those these little
details they kept me alive and touring
you know funnily enough no one really
Minds if it's like or it's just doesn't
make much of a difference because
everyone was supposed to go you know so
at first it was like oh do you guys even
care you know and and then it's like oh
now I understand that actually it you
know with communication the gestures
have grown the importance of putting the
foreground in the foreground has grown
and for me when I create things I'm sure
you guys would would relate a little bit
to this as well it's like the background
is in the foreground you know the
underneath sar in the foreground because
they're under the microscope but when
you perform that is the foreground you
are the foreground and I had to realize
that it's the same energy that goes in
words that goes out words when one
performs but you just need to polarize
the direction of that energy and then
you're fine and I didn't need to build a
sort of Jacob the champion who does
touring and excites people think it was
just like I just need to be myself but
in it in a different direction and so
it's just like falling off a log you
know you just sort of think what I'm
gonna be me today and I don't really
mind even if you like it very much but
it's just nice to see you it's sort of
attitude to Tory I hope that helps a
little bit
[Applause]
place where because I know you're a very
busy person but if you could like share
a little bit more of your insights with
me when you find the time
yeah very much enjoy that yeah it's a
date
to have Jacob part of our community we
hope he continues to be part of our
community and he's a world citizen these
days along with Ben and we thought it'd
be great to end with Jacob performing
for us Jacob Collier I just need to
apply some tape to my face with the help
of mr. Bloomberg so meet the harmonizer
here's a lovely beastie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the stars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know my love is true
[Music]
[Music]
softly
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come to go to the sea
[Music]
si Senor
[Music]
like you'll never see
[Music]
of course the
[Music]
Fedders fine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed
thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you ever so much thanks you guys
[Applause]
thank you so so much to me thank you so
so much to Fred thank you to Ben thank
you to Jump Street thank you to John and
thank you guys for coming along and
being a part of this very very special
evening I will not forget it in or in a
in a in a jiffy I'll be I'll be thinking
about this for a while it's been very
very special thank you so much for
coming and see you very soon
Thanks
you